[Music]
how many of you have tried fad diets I
use someone that's constantly looking
for shortcuts or that quick miracle
solution to lose weight well if you have
been following my videos you will know
that I am against any fad diets that are
restricted and only work short term the
sooner you start looking for the quick
solution and start making gradual
changes to your eating habits
the quicker you will start to see
permanent sustainable and real results
so what I want to share with you today
is a habit that will help you towards
your weight loss long term basically I
want you to start introducing soups into
your meal plan we don't always have to
eat only salad to be healthy or to lose
weight if you don't like salad then opt
for soup instead a bowl of homemade soup
has as many benefits and nutrients
compared to salad research has actually
shown that people who consume a bowl of
low-calorie soup before their meal ended
up eating about 20% less for their main
meal and they consume less total
calories throughout the day which led to
weight loss I'm not going to tell you to
only be eating soups and nothing else
because I don't think it's healthy and
you may end up feeling hungrier so for
the next 28 days here's what we're going
to do I want you to include at least two
servings of soups every day you can have
it either for breakfast lunch or dinner
choose only low-calorie vegetable or
broth-based
soup for instance chunky vegetables
pureed vegetables chicken or beef broth
avoid cream based soups especially those
loaded with heavy cream cheese or pasta
avoid instant can of powder soups those
soups tend to be very high in calories
sodium and fat which defeats the entire
purpose of adding soups into your diet
and if possible go for homemade soups if
you want to use ready soup stocks for
convenience then really read the food
labels go for low sodium and low-fat
options and here are 10 reasons why you
should add soups into your diet
it is very nutritious
you're basically getting a good balance
of protein carbs and healthy fats all in
One Bowl it gives you energy and keep
you going throughout the day you feel
full quicker and longer so the
combination of water and solid in soup
gives you up quicker and longer because
it expands in your stomach you reduce
your total calorie intake because soup
can fill you up on very few calories
eating soup on a daily basis means you
will eat less calories crave less feel
fuller which will help you to lose
weight and also maintain a healthy
weight long term you will increase your
water intake the basis of soup is
basically water so eating soup will
contribute to your total daily water
intake and keep you hydrated you get to
meet your five a day if you hate eating
your vegetables pureed vegetable soup is
the easiest way to add more vegetables
into your diet without feeling like
you're forced to eat your veggies it's
great for digestion so the high water
content of vegetables in soup promotes
healthy digestion by flushing out toxins
in the body so if you suffer from
constipation bloating or water retention
try adding soups into your diet it's
easy anybody can whip up a good bowl of
soup even if you can't cook it is very
difficult to mess up it's a one pot dish
so you can keep adding a little bit of
something or more of something until it
tastes good you can make a head weather
chilled or warm soups you can cook them
in large batches keep them chilled in
the fridge or freeze them up and reheat
we're ready to eat it is so convenient
and they will keep for many weeks it's
affordable vegetables broth and water
are cheap you can easily cook a large
pot of soup and a very low cost to feed
the entire family to keep them full and
healthy and it's very comforting no
matter what cultural background you're
from a bowl of soup is always very
comforting it is also very nourishing
restorative and
easily digested especially when we're
ill the recipes of making a hearty bowl
of soups are endless it can be served
hot and even chilled
so if you want soup recipes which don't
require cooking and you can take it out
with you
try my no cook chilled soup recipes they
are easy and very convenient no warming
up needed and you can eat it right away
if you prefer a bowl of warm cooked soup
then try out my three vegan slimming
soup recipes you can also mix them ahead
and freeze them up and they will last
for many weeks when you want to eat them
just kick them out defrost it and reheat
the soup and if you want to have soup as
your main meal then check out my eat
soup and stay slim recipes you can try
out at the soup noodles or make chunky
soup vegetables and add barley or even
rice into the mix all video links are
also available in my description box
below and when you eat out instead of
ordering your usual dish try to go for a
light broth base soup noodles such as
fer Iran soup miso ramen Tom Yum beef
noodles fish noodles chicken soup bean
soup and more so go and watch my soup
recipe videos make them and share your
pictures with me on Facebook and
Instagram again I am not recommending
you to only be eating soup and nothing
else
it's a well-balanced diet be consistent
with a water routine and add soups into
your meals to gain the benefits I want
you to keep me updated on your progress
so be sure to hashtag j-stop recipes and
hashtag 28 days soup challenge if you
enjoy this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up share it and subscribe to my
youtube channel for new weekly videos on
the best